hi Morty the ice cream corporation let
me tell you that they are in need of
slogans you should have heard their last
slogan what was it it was ice cream come
and taste it slips down your throat
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my rick and morty gravity
falls easter egg video there are a lot
of Easter eggs for gravity falls inside
Rick and Morty episodes in backgrounds
and because it's so amazing there's even
some Rick and Morty that showed up
inside gravity falls so we'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the easter
egg videos and really important I'll
talk about at the end of the video but
Adult Swim and Toro made a Rick and
Morty car that they let me borrow for a
little while so I'll talk about that at
the end of the video there's a little
under 20 of these well try to get to
this as fast as possible we'll start
with season one and work our way through
season two three and then up to four so
starting with season 1 episode 10 this
is the evil Morty debut on the series
when they're on the run from the Citadel
of Rick's and they're chasing each other
through successive portals to different
realities they jump into a dr. Seuss
reality
Rick opens a bunch of portals to confuse
them but if you look here the camera
lingers on it for a little while there's
a mug with a question mark on it a pen
and a notepad that come out of one of
the portals there's a scene at the end
of the gravity falls episode Society of
the blind eye at the episodes ending
there's a credits gag where Stan loses
those three exact things into a giant
portal alright getting closer
every day it's getting strong yeah I
don't care if it's dangerous I don't
care how long it takes I'm gonna pull
this off
and no one's gonna get in my way a lot
of people have tried to connect gravity
falls as being just an alternate reality
within the Rick and Morty multiverse at
the end of that same episode when
they're going home Rick is referencing
evil Morty and how cocky Morty's are a
very dangerous thing you see Morty
carrying a stack of books one of them
looks just like Journal three then in
season 2 episode 7 there's a picture of
gravity falls Bills cipher that can be
seen on a monitor while Beth and Jerry
are going to counseling most of the time
within Rick and Morty episodes the
gravity falls Easter eggs are either
bill cipher or something referencing one
of the journals right before season 3
started in real life Adult Swim did this
weird promotion on Instagram called the
rick's diverse which was released to
promote the season 3 April Fool's Day
episode everybody remembers the April
Fool's Day episode click on a tag and
then you can war to all sorts of
different planets and dimensions when
you go inside the federal prison there's
a room inside with a visible monitor in
the image of bill cipher shows up with a
symbol of Journal 3 one picture below it
you can also see a collection of Rick's
items in a tray next to one is labeled a
bunch of question marks and contains
three items that grunkle Stan lost
through his portal in the episode
Society of the blind eye which is the
Easter Egg that I just referenced a
second ago so I think we can assume that
Rick got his hands on the items after
the episode and just happened to have
them on his person when he was thrown
into prison at the end of season 2 then
in real life around this time the
gravity falls people in Disney released
a physical version of Journal 3 that you
could buy that contained a plumb bus' as
I journey on then in another page
there's a copy of Ford's wanted poster
with an encoded message on the corner
reading Rick was here as in Rick Sanchez
on the secondary page Ford also mentions
fist fighting with a talking chair which
may or may not be a reference to the
furniture universe with the talking
furniture within an actual gravity falls
episode - you see dipper looking through
Journal three and he comes upon
something called a dream hipster monster
that looks exactly like scary Terry from
Rick and more
with his kitchen utensils forefinger
blades instead of regular knives like
Freddy Krueger Nightmare on Elm Street
then during season 3 episode 1 in the
episode when Morty and summer get taken
to the Citadel of Rick's before the
council in the background you can see a
Mabel and dipper morty with him holding
journal 3 then in episode 5 world leader
lee conspiracy at the end of the episode
there's a tag scene with those little
aliens that escaped from the machine
without knowing it Beth had to let them
go and they're just lounging by the
stream if you look in the background
before they get carried off by one of
the hawks you actually see bill cipher
graffiti on the bridge then in episode 6
a lot of people notice the toxic Rick's
tuning tower was actually really close
to Oregon which is where gravity falls
is when you're actually inside the toxic
environment with toxic rick and toxic
morty you look you see it decaying
eight-ball that's actually one of Bill
ciphers allies from weirdmageddon little
Easter eggs like that especially stuff
that shows up in the background and
there's really hard a spot is usually
something that the animators add
themselves sometimes dan and Justin have
no idea of the easter eggs that get
included but their animators that also
worked on gravity falls that then work
on Rick and Morty so it explains how a
lot of that stuff winds up in the actual
episodes without most people knowing
about it during episode 7 the Rick
lantus mix-up tales of the Citadel you
actually see that giant crowd shot
there's a Stanford Pines Rick in that
opening scene where they're all walking
through the street together during that
next episode episode 8 there's a whole
bunch when they're running through the
MC Escher dream palace with the truth
tortoise they run by a statue that looks
a lot like bill cipher when they go into
the room in the basement with all the
archives of their experiences and
memories there's a memory vial with
Stanford written on it as in Stanford
Pines from gravity falls implied that
there are memories from gravity falls
that Morty has as if he's traveled there
there's another vial in that very same
scene that says bill C as in bill cipher
so it's almost as if Rick and Morty have
also encountered bill cipher and their
adventures during the scene where Morty
inadvertently causes the horrific death
of zik-zak he's actually an omae's
winner a person in real life too just
won a contest and got to voice that
alien he hands him a business card when
he meets him for the first time and on
the back there's a design that looks
exactly like blueprints of the gravity
falls entered
national portals even though the portals
work the same way on gravity falls in
Rick and Morty the portals themselves
look very different during episode 9
they have a concept called fruit peel
and that Rick creates to just keep Beth
busy so that she won't go around
terrorizing the neighborhood because she
was so scary as a child it's almost
exactly like the concept of Mabel's
Fantasyland created by bill cipher to
keep her busy because she was so
dangerous in a threat to his takeover of
gravity falls in the world later in the
episode when Rick is talking to Beth
about all the crazy things that she made
him invent he pulls out a police badge
the badge is a police badge from gravity
falls implying the Beth also visited
gravity falls when she was a little girl
a teaser shaped like a ladybug a fake
police badge a pink sentient switchblade
if you didn't see it there was obviously
the bonus episode done by tiara why
where you see Stanford Pines eating ice
cream with a version of Rick Sanchez
there's also some bill cipher graffiti
during that too between season 3 and
season 4 because Justin roiland and Alex
Hirsch creator of gravity falls are
friends in real life they did a charity
event together for h3h3 where they did
the voices for Rick Sanchez and grunkle
Stan together this is a clip from
probably about as close as we'll get to
an actual big crossover happening in
real life then the only reference that I
could find during season 4 so far is
season 4 episode 4 last week's episode
when Rick is using the magician's
portals he makes fun of him who writes
on portals well if you look at the
gravity falls portals all of Stanford
Pines portals have riding all over them
if you spotted any other big gravity
falls easter eggs during Rick and Morty
episodes or Rick and Morty stuff during
gravity falls episodes that I didn't
mention during the video just write it
below in the car
many thanks to the turo people for
letting me drive the morning mobile if
you guys are familiar with the concept
of the RIC mobile Adult Swim created a
car based on Rick Sanchez to drive
around and sell merch
now that partnered with Toro the world's
largest car sharing service to create a
car based on Morty's so they let me
drive it around for a little while the
difference between them and a
traditional car rental agency is that
they're peer-to-peer so you're actually
borrowing other people's really badass
cars you can also sign up to list your
car on the service and earn extra money
when people borrow it they're in about
fifty five hundred different cities in
the US the UK in Germany so ones are
pretty good the service is where you
live they're taking the more t-mobile to
a bunch of different cities in the u.s.
right now I believe it's headed to San
Francisco next so if you do want to
drive more tea around for a little while
there's a chance that you can do that
they're about thirty percent cheaper
than traditional rental car companies on
average they gave me a discount code to
give you guys that I'll add in the
description it's awesome fifteen is
fifteen dollars off on your first trip
but the price usually just depends on
what kind of car you want to borrow like
you could find a Tesla Model S you can
find Porsches so many thanks to the turo
people for letting me borrow the morning
mobile for a little while my full
episode five Easter Egg video will post
on Monday just like normal but if
they're any big bonus videos you want to
request just let me know in the comments
everyone click here for the brand-new
season 4 episode 5 trailer and click
here for my brand-new mandalorian
episode 6 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]